[Music]
velocity of the executive producer Brad
Pitt made a surprise and rare appearance
on the carpet
he looked noticeably thinner but happy
engaging with a cast kind of chatting
with everybody he skipped interviews but
the cast and director did tell me why he
was so important to this movie develop
this for years and years and I think
initially the intention was that he was
going to star on edge then he decided
just to produce it but you know it was
good for me whatever whatever the
decision was you know here we are
he found the book and developed it and
hired James and I think the producer was
very active he's obviously a very
hands-on ready to go he'll not know you
when you return I know this is a
sacrifice for all of us it won't be
worth it I heard a lot about Charlie
kind of keeping to himself on set what
was your interaction with him on set
versus kind of how he is now that you
guys are doing the press around
he was very methods in an amazingly
impressive way he was starving himself
all the time he didn't speak to his
fiancee at all he has an intensity and I
think it really resonates in the film
it's a tough job trying to bring
characters to life I just wanted to feel
lonely and like selfish and you know so
it worked you know and thankfully have
an incredible girlfriend who's very very
understanding and supportive
[Music]
you